so probably the most familiar use of
manifold learning came to biologist
consciousness with the rise of single
cell and single nuclei sequencing
technologies
you probably are very familiar with you
matt
embedding showing the clusters of cell
in some tissue
so for the next 15 or 20 minutes i will
try to walk you through a brief overview
of single cell sequencing i will go over
the sequencing technology that allows us
to study the gene expression on a single
cell or single nuclei level and we will
also mention some of the problems of the
field and some proposed solutions
so in the past it was possible to do rna
sequencing where all the cells would be
mixed up together
and then some average cell would be
quantified but as we all know very well
an average never actually exists in the
world so there's no average cell that
expresses this average profile of genes
and just about 10 years ago it has
become possible to quantify each
individual cell from the tissue on a
large scale and first people could
sequence hundreds of cells at a time
but today we can quantify the expression
of genes in thousands and even tens of
thousands of cells
in each sample at a time
and there are several
slightly different methods to obtain the
single cell or single nuclei data but
all of them have some basic steps
these steps include single cell
dissociation when the tissue
is treated with reagents to separate the
cells from each other
so they would later fit into a droplet
or a microwell
library construction where a special
bead is placed into a drop of oil or
microwell and each bead contains a cell
barcode and a molecule particle
so all rna molecules in a cell are
labeled with a cell barcode and
different molecule bar
and then the library is amplified and
sequenced
so as a result of the initial analysis
where the barcodes are recognized and
reads coming from specific cells are
sorted into those cells and also our
light of the genome to quantify the
expression of genes in each cell you get
a table where rows are genes or features
and columns are cells
and typically this table would consist
of about 20 000 rows so 20 000 genes and
thousands of cells in each sample
so what are the challenges of these data
large volumes of data
are generated in each experiment so each
cell is presented by expression of 20
000 genes so high dimensionality of data
low depth of sequencing
per cell and this means that the data is
sparse
many genes appear to have zero
expression expression
uh when in uh in reality they don't
and there is also variability across
samples
we call this batch effect
and these challenges are really driving
the field of single cell sequencing
forward
the research community has been really
invested in trying to overcome these
computational challenges
and also technological challenges
so
uh we at tauber have implemented a very
popular pipeline surah for analysis of
single cell sequencing and this pipeline
was developed in satijia lab at new york
genome center
the pipeline is a collection of r
packages and we have implemented this on
the tbi info to allow easier analysis
without the need to code or run r
scripts
the pipeline consists of several steps
of announcements first some
pre-processing is needed
these models help to clean out the
artifacts in the data so for example
doublets which are
droplets or microwells that have two
cells instead of one
and we can identify these doublets by
the amount of gene expressed in these
cells
so they are an outliers if we calculate
the overall expression of genes and in
the graph you i can see those as n
features
and we can also identify these cells by
the amount of molecules or here on the
graph called encounts
we can also throw out cells which are
undergoing stress
and we identify these cells by the
amount of mitochondrial genes in these
cells
and the assumption behind this is that a
large percent of genes that are
expressed in the cell are mitochondrial
these cells are highly stressed
perhaps due to the dissociation step of
the analysis or other steps of the
single cell sequencing
we could also regress out or take out
the effect of cell cycle changes
some researchers believe that regressing
out the cell cycle effect
normalizes the gene expression across
cells
and so the cells of the same time type
are more similar to each other than if
we would not regress out the cell cycle
however others have pointed out that the
knowledge of cell cycle effect might
reflect the underlying biology
and help elucidate important mechanisms
of the biological phenomena
next step of the analysis
if you have several samples
and you try to analyze them we need to
consider batch effect when uh
when we compare these biological samples
here you can see the single nuclei rna
sequencing data from kidney samples of
control mice group 1 and kidney samples
of diabetic mice group 2.
the dots are cells that are colored
based on their sample identity
you can see that before batch correction
samples are actually separated from each
other even though they belong to the
same group so in group one the green and
the orange
dots take up different parts of the umap
space
the same is in the group two blue and
pink dots are separated
in reality however we assume that cells
taken from the same biological
conditions would represent the whole
assembly of cell types
the whole cell populations and thus
would be spread out across the whole of
umap space
there are several algorithms that help
to eliminate this batch effect
and one algorithm is called harmony and
when we apply it to our data we see that
now
all samples are spread out across all
clusters and are mixed together so the
algorithm has successfully eliminated
this batch effect due to the sampling
next section of the single cell analysis
is manifold learning
and as we have seen in the previous
presentations manifold learning
algorithms are based on different
measure of distance and reveal different
structures
underlying our original data space
in single cell analysis perhaps the most
popular algorithm for representing the
data on a two-dimensional plane
is umap
and maybe it's a historical fact but if
you search through literature on a
single cell
analysis most likely you will see umac
dimensionality reduction figure in the
single cell article
so umap has been successfully uh
used to cluster cells into groups which
have similar gene expression profiles
and so probably belong to the same
biological cell type
the next part of the analysis workflow
is probably the most labor intensive and
most complicated and it is the
annotation of cell clusters by their
biological cell type
and here we rely on marker genes
either known markers of cells or
unsupervised markers of clusters
for example here again the kidney
dataset control kidney tissues compared
to diabetic diabetes tissue
one of the known markers of collecting
duct cells
is the gene
hsd-11b2 and we can grab this gene so
that the cell on the two-dimensional
plane using u-map so that cells that
express the gene highly are highlighted
in
yellow and we will see that the
highlight cluster on the umap space is
cluster number zero so we would identify
this cluster zero as a collecting duct
cells
another possibility is to find
unsupervised markers of cluster zero so
here you see
two genes that are expressed highly in
cluster
in cluster zero
while they are not expressed or
expressed in low amounts in other
clusters
and again you see here differentially
expressed markers for cluster zero the
dots here represent cells that are
expressing the gene
we can also visualize the expression of
genes as violent plots
in these plots we see expression levels
of this gene across all found clusters
of gene of cells so we see that the gene
wsvy1
is actually expressed in all of the
clusters
while
hsd11b2 is expressed in some of the
clusters but you can see that both wsb1
and
hsd11b2 is expressed most highly in
cluster number zero
so they are markers of this cluster
number zero
and as we have discussed we were lucky
this time and hsd 11
b2 is actually a known marker of
collecting duct cells
so in this way we could theoretically at
least annotate all of the clusters that
we have and as i said this part of the
analysis is
labor intensive
demands a lot of time biological
knowledge literature review and so on
so uh there have been many attempts to
automate this step
however the quality of annotation using
known tissue atlases depends on the data
set on the tissue you are studying and
also on the experimental procedure
because disease tissue or treated tissue
might change the expression of the known
markers and this will also be hard to
annotate
so at the moment this step is perhaps
the bottleneck of many projects
and it remains an active area of
research and also software development
and finally once you are satisfied with
the annotation step some differential
expression analysis can be done for
example if we would be interested in
identifying the genes that are
differentially expressed in the
collecting duct cells
in diabetes we could perform a
differential analysis inside cluster
zero for the two groups and identify
pathways and genes that are
differentially expressed in diabetes
compared to control cells
so
this is just basic steps of the analysis
of single cell
rna-seq data
thank you
you